hello Angelina lovely to see you so
we've thoroughly enjoyed these kind of
behind the scenes sneak peeks at you
guys getting ready how much of you
enjoyed having your family along for the
ride
oh it's so fun it makes it you know we
could get quite lonely if I was doing it
by myself and you know it's never fun to
focus on yourself anyway so when you're
when you're all taking care of each
other and you're making a game out of it
it's just a silly and it's it's nice for
me as a mom it's its moments I'm also
watching my kids grow up and watching my
daughter put on a beautiful dress and
figure out the right heels and all that
mom stuff that's just you know means a
lot how wonderful was it at the Tokyo
premiere reuniting with Maddox what did
he think I was I was very happy he was
you know I I don't know I'm so I I'm so
happy for him that he's grown up into
such a such a good man and he's and I
say that because he's smart and he's
doing his work but he's also wild and so
he's he's he's balanced in his in his
teenage years but it was fun he got
tattooed so you're back in the UK where
you shot this movie but also a few years
ago you got an honorary dame heard from
the Queen in 2004 so is this something
your kids know about what do they think
they did and I think well yeah I was
actually really proud of that because it
was for work in Foreign Service and so
they know about that work and I think
they thought it was I think they thought
it was cool but I don't I don't know we
haven't really talked about it
you